un groupe de migrants face à la police
anti-émeute la confrontation ici est
quasi quotidiennes entre ceux qui
veulent passer vers la grande bretagne
et ceux qui cherchent à les en empêcher
le nombre de candidats à l'asile en
europe est en constante hausse
et bon nombre d'entre eux voient le
royaume uni comme un eldorado pour faire
face à l'afflux la france et la grande
bretagne ont décidé de joindre leurs
forces
londres financera l'installation de
nouvelles clôtures de sécurité de caméra
surveillance et enverra des policiers
pour épauler les escouades française
chargée de lutter contre les passeurs
nous devons casser ces groupes criminels
dit la ministre britannique de
l'intérieur
selon son homologue français les
résultats de la coopération se font déjà
sentir
nous avons réussi à diminuer
considérablement le nombre d'intrusions
puisqu'elles ont été divisées par dix au
cours des dernières semaines mais les
mesures annoncées sont loin de faire
l'unanimité
car beaucoup ici craignent que plus de
clôture comme celle-ci érigés le long de
l'autoroute qui mène à l'angleterre ne
mène à plus de situations comme celle ci
un bidonville où sont bloqués des
milliers de réfugiés un bidonville qui
ne cesse de grandir
jour après jour des tentes à perte de
vue et autant de cas désespérés ils
viennent d'afghanistan d'erythrée du
soudan et ont tous fui la guerre
karim lui arrive de syrie il a déjà
traversé sept pays et dépensé plus de 12
mille dollars pour venir jusqu'ici sa
destination ultime c'est l'angleterre
il en rêve depuis toujours et soir après
soir ils tentent la traversée
rien ne peut l'en décourager
ils peuvent construire autant de
barrières qu'ils veulent on va continuer
d'essayer jusqu'à ce qu'on passe dit il
ce n'est qu'une question de temps je
n'abandonnerai jamais
nous vivons un état d'esprit très
répandue le plan qu'a annoncé
aujourd'hui pour nous n'est pas une
solution
ce qui fait dire à françois guennoc aux
travailleurs humanitaires présents ici
depuis le printemps que la france et la
grande bretagne font fausse route
plus de barrières plus de policiers ça
décourage pas les gens certains ont
attendu que il ya d'autres possibilités
de passage certains tentent ailleurs il
ya plus de morts plus de blessés il ya
énormément de blessés sur le bidonville
en fin de journée les migrants comme
karim quitte par centaines le camp pour
tenter une nouvelle fois la traversée
malgré la difficulté malgré les risques
parce que tous ici estime n'avoir plus
rien à perdre ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada calais